we just learned for a while ago that
there has been a shooting in El Paso at
this point the area has still not been
cleared it's still considered an active
you know that a lot of injury a lot of
suffering in El Paso right now
I'm incredibly sad and it's very hard to
think about this but I'll tell you
El Paso is the strongest place in the
world
this community's gonna come together
I'm going back there right now to be
with my family
and I want to thank Hill Paso Police
Department and the first responders that
they are they're there right now and
we're going back to me with them and
spoken to the mayor of el paso de Margo
spoken to congresswoman Escobar spoken
to sheriff Wiles they are all doing
everything that they can and we're still
learning information about this
situation so I just asked for everyone's
strength or I'll pass it right now
everyone's resolved to make sure that
this does not continue to happen in this
country and we'll be sharing more as I
won or going forward